>> Sean: HERSCHEL WALKER AND
INCUMBENT SENATOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK ARE HEADED TO A DECEMBER
RUNOFF IN GEORGIA AS NEITHER
CANDIDATE HIT THE 50% THRESHOLD
TO WIN OUTRIGHT, A RACE THAT
WILL LIKELY DETERMINE SENATE
CONTROL.
ASK YOURSELF, HOW MANY GEORGIA
VOTERS STILL DON'T KNOW ALL THE
DETAILS ABOUT WARNOCK'S EXTREME
RECORD, PAST SCANDALS, LIKE, YOU
KNOW, CALLING COPS, COMPARING
THEM TO THUGS AND GANSTERS,
ACCUSED AFTER A DOMESTIC DISPUTE
WITH HIS EX-WIFE, TRYING TO USE
A CAR TO RUN HER OVER, RAN OVER
HER FOOT.
THIS IS NOW TIME TO EXPOSE ALL
OF IT.
HERSCHEL WALKER JOINS US.
HERSCHEL, I WOULD IMAGINE, YOU
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE GOTTEN
50% PLUS ONE, BUT I ALSO GOT TO
IMAGINE, YOU NEVER THOUGHT YOU'D
GET INTO POLITICS.
HERE YOU ARE, IN A RUNOFF, IN
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RACES THIS ELECTION SEASON, THAT
WILL HAVE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON
THIS COUNTRY.
>> WELL, IT IS, SEAN.
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT I'D EVER DO
THIS.
BUT I THINK THE LORD PREPARED ME
FOR A MOMENT LIKE THIS RIGHT
HERE, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I KNOW
THAT A VOTE FOR HERSCHEL WALKER
IS A VOTE THAT THE GEORGIA
PEOPLE'S VOICES CAN BE HEARD IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., NOT ONLY THE
PEOPLE IN GEORGIA, BUT AMERICA'S
VOICES COULD BE HEARD, BECAUSE A
VOTE FOR SENATOR WARNOCK WILL
HAVE KAMALA HARRIS MAKING THE
DECISION FOR HIM.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT.
PEOPLE HAVE SEEN ME FIGHT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO BUY THIS SEAT.
THEY'LL DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO BUY THIS SEAT.
I'M GOING TO NEED YOUR HELP, TO
SAY, GUYS, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
LET THEM BUY THIS SEAT.
GO TO TEAMHERSCHEL.COM.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT.
THEY'LL HAVE TO COME THROUGH ME
TO GET TO YOU.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
>> Sean: I LOOK AT THIS
BACKGROUND, AND WONDER IF PEOPLE
THAT JUST WANT A REGULAR STEADY
DEMOCRATIC, YOU KNOW, VOTE, A
STEADY VOTE, AND THEY LOOK AT
WARNOCK AS BASICALLY A RUBBER
STAMP.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIS RECORD,
HERE YOU HAVE A GUY THAT WANTS
TO END CASH BAIL, LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER, COPS ARE COMPARED TO
THUGS AND GANGSTERS.
YOU LOOK AT THE REST OF HIS
RECORD.
CRT IN SCHOOLS BEING TAUGHT.
HE'S GOT A TERRIBLE TRACK
RECORD.
HE RAN A CAMP, AND THERE WERE
ALLEGATIONS OF CHILD ABUSE.
HE WAS ARRESTED FOR OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
YOU KNOW, PRAISING FARRAKHAN,
JEREMIAH WRIGHT, FIDEL CASTRO.
ARE PEOPLE IN GEORGIA AWARE OF
ALL OF THIS?
I THINK IF THEY WERE, I LIVED IN
GEORGIA FOUR YEARS.
THAT'S NOT THE GEORGIA THAT I
KNOW THAT WOULD VOTE FOR PEOPLE
THAT THINK LIKE THAT.
>> WELL, YOU SAID SOMETHING
EARLIER.
THE MEDIA IS NOT MY FRIEND.
THE MEDIA ARE GOING TO PUT MY
RECORD OUT THERE.
YET I'VE BEEN TRANSPARENT WITH
EVERYTHING I'VE EVER DONE.
HE HASN'T.
LET'S NOT JUST TALK ABOUT THAT
RECORD.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HIM AS A
SENATOR.
AS A SENATOR, HE GETS AN "F."
HE HAS NOT SPOKEN FOR THE
GEORGIA PEOPLE.
I THINK THE PEOPLE HAVE SEEN WHO
HE REPRESENT.
HE REPRESENT JOE BIDEN AND THE
PEOPLE THERE IN WASHINGTON,
BECAUSE HE'S VOTED WITH THEM 96%
OF THE TIME.
WE DON'T NEED TO KEEP SAYING
THAT.
THEN I THINK THE PEOPLE CAN FEEL
IT.
THEY CAN SEE IT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN A TIEBREAKER.
THAT'S WHY I SAID I'M NOT GIVING
THIS SEAT UP, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THE GEORGIA PEOPLE ARE HURT
BECAUSE OF THIS INFLATION.
THE GEORGIA PEOPLE ARE HURTING
BECAUSE OF CRIME ON THE STREET.
KIDS RIGHT NOW GOT MEN AND WOMEN
SPORTS.
ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
HAPPEN IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS
SINCE HE'S BEEN OFFICE.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET THEM
CONTINUE TO DESTROY GEORGIA AND
THIS COUNTRY.
I'M GOING TO KEEP FIGHTING.
WE GOT LESS THAN A MONTH.
I CAN PUT UP WITH A MONTH,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THIS SEAT IS A
LOT BIGGER THAN HERSCHEL WALKER.
I KNOW THEY'LL THROW MORE AT ME,
EVEN THE KITCHEN SINGER, BUT I N
CATCH IT.
I'LL CATCH IT AND KEEP MOVING
FORWARD.
>> Sean: I WOULD ARGUE, THAT'S
PROBABLY TRUE.
WILL IT WILL BE AS UGLY AS IT
CAN BE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY CAN SAY
WHATEVER THEY WANT ABOUT YOU,
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT ON HIM AND
HIS POSITIONS AND HIS STATEMENTS
OVER THE YEARS.
I HOPE THAT THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA GET EDUCATED ON ALL OF
THIS, BECAUSE IF THEY DO, I
BELIEVE YOU WIN HANDS DOWN.
HERSCHEL WALKER,
CONGRATULATIONS.
LOOK FORWA